I am Daniel Daniel I am the lead data
scientist with a company called tackler
which you'll hear a little bit more
about here in a bit and I co-host
upcoming podcasts called practical a guy
today I'm going to talk about compliant
data management and machine learning at
scale so being a data income pretty much
all of that title except for one word is
really easy to get excited about we all
love doing data and machine learning at
scale but for some reason when I add on
the compliant part we all kind of get
sad right and and maybe a little bit
concerned so I think that that reaction
is kind of telling in the sense that as
data scientists as data engineers we're
concerned that maybe we aren't being
compliant and we're going to get sued or
maybe we don't understand what it means
to be compliant in certain cases we
don't know if we have to be compliant to
certain regulations and we don't we
think it might be a hassle to implement
what we need to be compliant so
hopefully today you know with the talk
I'll give you kind of a little bit of
assurance around that that there are
actually ways to do the things that we
really love to do you know like all
sorts of weird deep learning stuff but
at the same time you know have these
workflows be compliant with
ever-increasing regulation so the first
thing I'm going to talk about is what
exactly we're talking about in terms of
compliance there's a lot of maybe
different ideas about what what that
means and of course there's a lot of
regulations out there and then I'm going
to talk and kind of hopefully motivate
some guidelines that really will help us
build data pipelines that are
sustainable over time in the midst of
kind of increasing and changing
regulations and then I'll kind of
present a solution and and hopefully do
a demo or at least show screenshots
depending on how that goes and leave a
bunch of time for Question and Answer so
what is the compliance that I'm talking
about of course there's you know a lot
of like I said a lot
different types of regulation out there
when it comes to processing data I don't
know about you guys but kind of probably
you know the the main thing that I think
of when I first think of compliance are
certain industries where compliance has
been an issue for a very long time right
so if you're working with like health
care data or financial transaction data
or something like that then you're
you're not unfamiliar with regulation
and trying to be compliant but actually
you know increasing and I really don't
have to tell you guys this because it's
you know all over the news pretty much
every day we more and more are seeing
regulations geared towards kind of
general data processing and kind of
anyone that's processing data and making
algorithmic decisions so you know
obviously there's a lot going on in the
states right now with people talking
about you know how should we regulate I
think people like Facebook but you know
things are already passed in that you
the GEEP are if you're not familiar with
that has has brought about a lot of
regulations that go into effect I think
like in a month but basically these
regulations a lot of them are geared
towards kind of anyone that's processing
you know people's data to make decisions
and so that pretty much covers you know
probably most people in these 3 e3
conference rooms and so this kind of
type of general regulation is what I'm
going to focus on and so I kind of see
this as a few different pieces that you
can think about the course there's
industry specific regulations in terms
of like health care or financial
transactions some of those involved you
know just inherently private data like
credit card numbers or social security
numbers that maybe need to be an
anonymizer you process them but then
there's also you know the idea like I
mentioned the idea of kind of general
regulations around any type of data
you're processing even if you're not in
health care or finance so that last bit
is when I'm going to folk
here if you're interested in other
things around anonymization and managing
private data I would definitely
recommend looking at Jim clue cars talks
from Munich he actually spoke at data in
Japan I think last go-around and he has
some some really great insights there
but they kind of give an example of what
I'm talking about I think a good example
of this is you know there have actually
already been people you know suing
Google around around autocomplete so you
know like you type your name in to like
Google search and then it'll say like
you know Daniel white nack is a you know
blank and it's gonna fill in something
right and if it it might say some nice
things but maybe it says they know why
not is a fraud or something like that
well I mean Google is just processing
you know words and data is it's not
really managing like my credit card info
or my social security number or
something like that but it has this
complicated pipeline behind the scenes
that is really feeding this autocomplete
mechanism right and so more and more you
know people are concerned with what
you're doing with whatever data you're
processing to produce you know certain
results that might not you know might
not ever have anything to do with
processing you know inherently private
data right so that's a that's a type of
compliance that I'm going to talk about
and really you know like I mentioned
there's a lot of different regulations
and I must clarify that I'm not a lawyer
I'm not trying to give you legal advice
I'm just trying to give you some
examples so like generally we're seeing
kind of a move towards regulations that
are pushing for like transparency or
explanation of all the things you did to
process data to create a specific result
including like transformations and
generation of data access to data who
accessed it along the way and so you
know in general you know in thinking
about kind of things
to the GDP are what we need to be
striving for is the ability to say for
any particular result that we generate
whether that's like projecting someone
for insurance or you know creating
something some result for autocomplete
right whatever those things are we need
to be able to stitch back all of the
different pieces of data and processing
that actually led to that particular
result being in created and so we need
to have some transparency around all of
those things that led to produce result
okay so that can be a little bit so
that's like the downer side of of my
talk so we're through that so everybody
come to the front so that's that's the
downer side because I don't know about
you but when I think about that I know
that are like I don't work for Google
but I'm guessing that all of the
different things that lead to that that
end result of the autocomplete of Daniel
one hand is a fraud in search it's
relatively complicated hey it's not just
like one Python script running in the
background that you know does one thing
it takes in one file and outputs another
file right that's not what we're talking
about if you were actually talking about
complicated pipelines and so when we
want to think about staying compliant
and providing this sort of transparency
and explanation we have to think about
more than the things that are you know
generally talked about at you know in
blog posts and in tutorials and by that
I mean you know we often talk about like
the training bit of data science machine
learning and AI model training and we
talk about maybe doing inferences or
serving that model but that's only you
know a really small piece of this puzzle
you know leading up to that there's a
lot of data cleaning there's a lot of
feature engineering and model selection
that goes on potentially there's further
data transfer me
and kind of post-processing an
optimization that might be paired with
with training and then of course there's
you know further transformations and
post-processing potentially around
inference right and all of these
different pieces of processing might be
done by different systems by different
languages and frameworks in different
ways and also each one of these produces
input and output data right and so if
we're thinking about like needing to
provide transparency to getting through
this process there's a lot of different
pieces of data and processing that we
need to manage and that we need to
understand and provide an explanation
for but also all of those things are
stitched together in a certain way right
like if I just kind of provide someone
with all this data and processing right
they're going to have absolutely no idea
how I actually got to a particular
result right
so it takes putting the right data into
the right processing at the right time
on the right
you know infrastructure to actually
produce a certain result and so in
thinking about like what do we need to
do for this sort of pipeline in order to
get to a place where we have that
ability to explain our processing or we
have transparency into our processing
I've kind of come up with three things I
think that we need a framework for
managing and defining these workflows
that's really data and language agnostic
it's like I said you know data science
and data engineering is always going to
involve a lot of different frameworks a
lot of different systems and languages
and a lot of different types of data
already this morning I've heard about
you know probably 20 different things
that you know every person is using
right so we need to be able to do this
in some sort of unified way to even have
a
providing transparency but we also need
to pair with that a new kind of type of
versioning okay so it's actually not
about in these cases to version your
code so even if you know what code you
ran into say train a certain model write
your model and those corresponding
inferences downstream are going to be
vastly different depending on what data
you fed into that model right depending
on what parameters you you used and what
sampling you used in your data and so
it's actually not enough to version code
alone we need to version data we need to
version models and we need to version
what processing was done at what time to
produce what other data write to be able
to stitch back and say this particular
result came from this particular version
of my model which was trained using this
particular version of my code which I
provided input to with this particular
raw data right and finally this is
probably you know maybe more obvious in
the context of this talk but of course
we need to provide access controls
around the data processing that we're
doing so that we can not only say that
this data came from this model which was
using this code but we can say you know
this particular user committed this
particular change in data which trigger
these things downstream and thus
eventual result okay so those are all
the things that you know I propose that
we mean it turns out that you know
people have have been working on this in
in various ways and I'm going to present
you with kind of one solution and this
is the solution that we have catheter
have been kind of helping clients
implement and you know there's a lot of
people running this in production to
actually stay compliant and provide this
sort of transparency into the
we're closed so pack whatever if you
don't know it's a it's an open source
state of pipelining and data management
layer for kubernetes kubernetes if
you're not familiar is a container
Orchestrator and so hacker involves a
few different main features but I'm
going to kind of tie these back to the
things that we were kind that we are
hoping to achieve in order to provide
transparency and to our into our
workflow the first thing remember that
we wanted is a unified way to deal with
all sorts of languages and frameworks
that we have in our data pipelines and
because pachyderm is running on top of
kubernetes we can easily utilize
containers for analysis
so docker containers so this allows us
to kind of unify every stage of
processing as defined by a container and
that means you can use whatever
languages and frameworks you want
everything from Python and R in Java and
C++ and batch commands whatever you want
to run all those can be managed in a
unified way and then we combine those
into kind of a data pipeline where each
of those those stages of the pipeline is
defined by containers and this is
actually a distributive data pipeline so
actually every stage of that data
pipeline you can individually scale and
manage the resources associated with it
and the other two features remember the
other goal that you're really striving
for is a new kind of versioning system
that versions both data and encode and
so Packer provides that the Idina
versioning and which filters down into
this idea of data provenance of this
ability to kind of tie specific results
back to all the data and processing that
led to those particular results so in my
remaining time I'm just going to kind of
pull up I have a demo running up here
which if you can't see from where you're
sitting I'll have this pulled up at
lunchtime
so feel free to stop by and talk but
this is a pachyderm dashboard and I've
got two two pipelines up and running in
this pachyderm cluster and if I click on
any one of these pipelines here I can
see the one of the first things that
I've mentioned so each of these is
defined each of these processing stages
is defined by a docker container a
command that's run in that docker
container and input data that's input to
that that container for processing and
that's true of whatever whatever
pipeline I'm looking at or whatever
stage I'm looking at and it's not just
Python or scikit-learn here I'm using
open CV over on this side to process
images you could use R whatever you want
so I'm managing all of this in a unified
way it's all defined in a unified way so
it's very easy to manage and the second
thing we talked about remember was the
data versioning and the data provenance
so if I looked at one of these blue
icons here this represents each one of
the blue icons represents a different
collection of data that I'm processing
in my pipeline and up here at the top
you can see that there's some metadata
about the versioning of that data set
and so you can see here that I've made
three commits of data into this data set
I can actually go back in time to any
one of those and see oh and this one
there were two files right and in my
original one there was there was one
file and when I when I actually version
that data and I'm processing version
data in this data pipeline then the
result that we want this idea of tying
any result back to all of the stages of
processing and data that contributed to
that result kind of comes out naturally
so for example if I go to some result in
my pipeline
these are inference
those that are being made I can see that
I that I've had two outputs of this
pipeline and I didn't click on any
version of them and see all the upstream
commits of data that led to that
particular inference so in this case I'm
doing machine learning inference so I
can actually go back to the particular
version of my model that created that
particular inference and I can do that
for any result no matter how many times
I updated my pipeline how many times I
changed my model and how many times I
ran my inference so if you're interested
in more of that definitely come come and
talk to me after the after the talk or
at lunchtime I can show you a little bit
more details and here I'll just go back
in the slides I tweeted these out so you
can if the you can get the links as well
but you can run all of this locally like
I said it's all open source so you can
pull it up all on your local machine and
and run it locally we have a public
slack channel if you want to ask
questions and get help with these sorts
of things there's a link to the docs and
so thank you guys
hi thank you for your talk
I'm actually process of building on
something similar for detailed in
general very similar in architecture
perhaps a little more functional but in
any case I'm curious when you retain all
of those essentially good notes right do
you hold on to what the machine image
identifier is as well that the code is
actually running on so you have a
complete environment yeah so all of that
so there's actually multiple components
here right if you want to actually
reproduce something you need the version
of the of all the input data which we
get from the data versioning you need
the exact code that was run in the in
the exact environment so that you did
from the docker image which ideally is
tied back via its tag to the github hash
that includes that but then also in the
log so that we have I didn't show it
here but we have kind of what we call an
advanced job statistics function where
you would actually be able to see for
any job diagram you would be able to see
the particular data about a process and
on which nodes it process that data so
for instance if you're running like
distributed tensorflow or attempt to
flan and GPU or something like that you
can get in the exact node and
information
and it's very cool so obviously we're
operating generally an assumption the
storage is cheap nowadays but it's not
free so in a world where we have very
large amounts of intermediate data the
restoring and older versions that
immediate data might get deleted for
cost savings how does that impact us
rent traceability yeah so a great
question
so um first like in terms of the space
efficiency of the versioning we don't
use get under the hood just because it's
not efficient in this way we have our
own way of versioning which is based on
content addressing your data as it comes
into the system on the fly so what that
means is like if you put in like a
million images right we're going to
content address each of those and store
it but if you updated that data settle
and so you updated like a thousand
images right we're not going to store
another copy of the million images like
the new state right we're only going to
copy or we're only going to update the
data that changed so now we were able to
be kind of like D duping on the fly but
then in terms of like if you actually
want to garbage collect things over time
you can definitely still retain like the
metadata associated with what was the
process that what time by what code for
example but if you actually delete that
state of data and garbage collected I
mean there's there's nothing that we can
really do which in that case you know
it's back to similar you know maybe not
similar systems but other systems that
just track mad metadata right if you're
just tracking metadata that it doesn't
really get you all the way to the finish
line depending on what you need
yeah just kind of jump off of that so do
you what's what's kind of the ratio in
terms of its storage size between inputs
and resulting machines eight one of the
things that I'm doing for the BPL stuff
which is probably a very different ratio
is I only hang on ticket points and then
the outputs long enough to serve
whatever you know a high pedestal points
to a price it's like garbage collect
everything else right so I don't I can
reproduce everything right so it doesn't
no matter what's the ratio between input
size and resulting machine state size so
when you say a machine state size you
mean in terms of like the output living
on the particular node that it was
processed on whatever it is that you're
snapshotting has yes it's a great
question so actually all all of the
cluster and all of the processing even
though it's processing you know data is
completely stateless so all of the data
is backed in a backing object store so
as that output is generated that's
actually passed back into the objects or
into kind of the distributed file system
which is art essentially are layer on
top of the object store so like after
that processing happens the data that's
on that note for that worker is gone
it's only gone
I mean the machine learning he'll go
state with that okay yeah so I mean that
that depends very much on like what so
again one of our goals is the framework
of language agnostic and so that means
that we'll version whether you're using
a pickle file or protobuf or whatever it
is so it will very much depend on like
your your network size whether you're
saving just the parameters of the whole
state of the network and save export or
something like that also depend on the
format that you using on the output you
know there's a lot of different
different formats now so we we basically
don't we don't add anything to that
particular file we just pumped and
aggressive and create a hash so the only
additional data in addition to the model
binary would be like a single entry of a
key value store
you